وانا احييكم من مشاهدينا من جديد في لبنان
بات حزب الله هو المستفيد الوحيد ورايسي
من الازمات المتتاليه التي تمر بها البلاد
وفقه مراقبين التطورات الحاصله حيث يوصلوا
الحزب تحقيق اهدافه غير المشروعه وهذه
المره من خلال توسيع نشاط جمعيه القرض
الحسنه التي يصفها اللبنانيون بانها
المصري في المركزي ولي حزب الله في ضمن
استراتيجيه جديده تقوم بتعزيز نشاطها ضمن
مناطق سيطره الحزب وتوسيعه وجودها لطلب
مناطق جديده على حساب المصارف الشرعيه
العامله في السوق التي باتت اعمالها
محدوده فروعنا جديده سيتم اعتمادها في
منطقه السوق الغير في جبل لبنان حيث سيكون
الفرع الجديد في المنطقه او ولا فرعا ضمن
منطقه تختلف بطبعها الديني عن مناطق اخرى
وهنا كشفت مصادر مطلعه ان حزب الله قام
بشراء قطعه ارض في منطقه فوق الغرب من اجل
بناء شديد للمؤسسه ورئيس البلديه اعطاها
ترخيصا بذلك وفق مراقبين
فتوسعون نشاطات جمعيه القرض الحسن دليل
على قيام دوله غير شرعي
مصدر تمويلها من اموال غير نظيفه خصوصا
وانها لا تخضع لي قانون النقدي والتسليف
في حين ترى مصادر ان توسع نشاط القرض
الحسن ما رده هو عدم تقيده بالقوانين
المصيفيه وهو ما سهلات حوله الى مؤسسه
لتبويض الاموال فهي استفاده من تحول
الاقتصاد اللبناني الى اقتصاد النقدي
وباتت مؤسسه مصرفيه تعطي القروض على عكس
النصارى في اللبنانيه الشرعيه
[موسيقى]
هناك شهاده ملف مع ضيفنا من بيروت ملكه
بنادر الكاتب الصحفي وبعد قليل ربما هو
المفروض ينضم لنا كذلك من بيروت
في حزب القوات اللبنانيه في انتظار ان
يجهز ضيف ناس ابدا معك يا استاذ مالك
نحاول ان نفهم كيف تسير الامور خاصه
هي مؤسسه لا تموت باي صله او علاقه للبنك
المركزي اللبناني تشتغل بطريقه غير شرعيه
غير قانونيه بحسب ما يقول اللبنانيون
وتتوسع كيف ذلك
مساء الخير اول انا اعتقد ان هذه جمعيه
جمعيه تعاونيه
للترخيصا نالت ترخيصا من من السلطات
المختصه وزاره الداخليه وزاره الشؤون
الاجتماعيه
وبدايه كانت تعنى كانت تعنى باعطاء قروض
صغيره بدون فائده غير كروت تجاريه لانها
تتبع النظام الاسلامي اي انها لا لا تبغي
الربا والربا تعطي قروض مساعدات لبعض
المحتاجين او حتى لبعض البلديات ولكن يبدو
ان مشكله المشكله المصرفيه في لبنان ادت
الى ان
ادت بالكثيرين الى ان همم الى ان يوظفوا
اموالهم لديها ولكن بطريقه بطريقه همم ااا
غير ااا غير مشابهه للموضوع المصري في
المالي اي ان ااه
حسبا حسب ما اعلم انا وحسب ما
حسب ما اظهرت بعض التحقيقات والتي نشرت
انه يستطيع اي لبناني عن ااا ان يضع
اموالا ان يضع اموالا في هذه المؤسسه ان
يضع همم
تقديمات عينيه كذهب او عقاره وكذا وياخذ
مقابل همالا مؤسسه
رهن واقراض وهذه همم وهذه همم مؤسسات او
جمعيات هناك الكثير منها في السوق
اللبناني ولكن همم كان القرض الحسن ده تبع
النظام الاسلامي قد اتبع النظام الاسلامي
اعتقد ان لها اعتقد ان لها همم لها صوره
خاصه
التي تذكر فيها النظام الاسلامي للبنوك
وهذا يكثر في الحديث لانه لما تقول بان هي
مؤسسه همم اا تعطي همم قروض وكانك وصفت
هذه القروض في شكل هبات دون ربى هناك شكل
خاص من اشكال الاقتراض في هذه البنوك
الاسلاميه وهذا ليس موضوعنا ولكن همم
حضرتك تقدمها على انها همم الحل الحالي في
خضم الازمه اللبنانيه وهنا سؤالي سيد جاد
صرت جهز معنا هل هذه المؤسسات وان كانت
همم غير تابعه للبنك المركزي اللبناني
ومعرفه بانها غير شرعيه همم هي الحل
الحقيقي
بالطبع لا منطق الضوي لا لا يقوم الا من
خلال تدمير منهج للدوله وهذا ما حصل في
الفتره الاخيره منذ سطو حزب الله على كافه
المؤسسات الشرعيه في لبنان
وذهب بتدمير ممنهج وصل اليوم الى حد وجود
بعض المؤسسات التي هي غير شرعيه التي هي
غير خاضعه للرقابه الداخليه ولا للخارجيه
وبالتالي تقوم بعمل ااا ما يفترض بان تقوم
به الدوله اللبنانيه والمصري في المركزى
هذا هو من ضمن سياق طويل بضرب مؤسسات
الدوله ضرب السياده اللبنانيه ضرب القرار
الاستراتيجي ضرب كل ما يتصل بالميز
التفاضليه للبنان نحن نعلم جيدا بان
المصارف في لبنان لا طالما كانت جاسب
اساسي لكافه المواطنين ان كان في لبنان او
في خارج لبنان اليوم من خلال هكذا مؤسسات
غير خاضعه للرقابه غير خاضعه للاقتصاد
اللبناني الداخليه تقوم على انقاذ ما تبقى
من مؤسسات في لبنان استاذ مالك يعني هذه
هي المؤسسه هي مؤسسه يمكن القول بانها
تدعم او همم تفتت الداخل اللبناني
اقتصاديا تزيده ازمه على ازمته ما رايكم
اعتقد انه حتى الان همم لا يستطيع احد ان
يجبر احد ان يساهم في هكذا مؤسسه هناك
تقديمات او هناك ربما ااه
تسهيلات تقدمها هذه المؤسسه استطاعت ان
تجذب اصحاب الاموال من
طائفه معينه لنقول ليستثمر لان لديهم ثقه
بمؤسسات حزب الله وهذا هذا لا لا يمكن
انكاره في الوسط الذي
يتحرك الدوله
اعتقد ان اعتقد انها انه لو كان النظام
المصري في اللبناني سليم واستطاع ان يحافظ
على اموال المذيعين لا حاجه لا حاجه لاي
كان لكي يذهب الى مؤسسات اخرى انا لا ابرر
ولكن اقول انها قد قد شكلت او قد تشكلوا
ملازا مقبولا تبعا لما حصل لاموال
المذيعين
والاستثمارات ولل التعب وعرق همم الموظفين
والمتقاعدين في لبنان اعتقد انها شكلت
بديلا وللاسف على همم لا اضع اللوم على
على من يديرها على الدوله اللبنانيه
طلع المشكله في همم همم النظام المصري في
اللبناني
سيدتي العزيزه نحن نعلم جيدا بان هنالك
عقوبات دوليه على حزب الله وبالتالي هنالك
العديد من الاشخاص والكينات التابعه لهذا
الحزب تجد بان هنالك ملف هذا الملاذ الغير
شرعي من اجل بان تستمر باعمالها التي هي
غالبا ما تكون خارج نطاق الاقتصاد الداخلي
وخارج نطاق العمليات القانونيه المشكل ليس
ب همم ان هنالك اا ازمه اقتصاديه في لبنان
اقتصاديه وازمه ماليه وازمه مصرفيه ولكن
المشكله الاساس هو بمن اوصلنا الى مجموعه
هذه المشاكل التي هي همم مشاكل على كافه
المشكله الاساسي لانه ذلك من وضع لبنان
هذه المؤسسه هي مؤسسه تعمل همم
او لاسباب همم اخرى غير ما تقدم به ضيف من
خليل وهو محاوله فتح المجال لمساعده الدخل
اللبناني على تخطي ازمه تقول بانه لا
لديها اهداف اخرى ما هي
الاهداف هي الابقاء على ملاذ امن لكافه
العمليات التي تدور بفلك حزب الله ونحن
نعلم جيدا بان هنالك عقوبات دوليه
وبالتالي البيئه الحاضنه لحزب الله او
الاساسيين في هذه البيئه لا يستطيعون
بامتلاك همم عمليات قانونيه 100% وهم
يخشون بالتعرض للعقوبات الدوليه المفروضه
ما نراه اليوم التفاف على هذه العقوبات من
خلال مؤسسه لست انا من يقول بل المصرف
المركزي والدوله اللبنانيه هي من تكون بان
هذه المؤسسه هي غير شرعيه وهي غير قانونيه
والاعمال التي تقوم بها هي خارج اطار
القانون المصري في اللبناني وبالتالي
العديد من التساؤلات تطرح في هذا المجال
الصالحه من اي سيد مالك ذكرت وزاره
التجاره
من همم من وزاره الداخليه وزاره الشؤون
الاجتماعيه ومن وزاره الماليه كمؤسسه
اقراض ورع انقاذاري
انه يجب الاطلاع على ذلك
لكي لا نقول لكي لا نقول هي مؤسسه
هذه المؤسسه تعمل منذ العام منذ عام 2001
لماذا لماذا تكاثر وانتشرت الان واصبحت
الان في في الضوء الاعلامي كما قلت للاسف
لان النظام المصري في اللبناني انكسر همم
ادى الى افلاسات وادى الى كذا لا جاءت بعض
همم مجتمع معيا الى الى همم الى هذه
المؤسسه الاعتقاديه انها قد تقول انها قد
تكون ملازا اخر
المشكله انا لبنانيين يقولون بان هذه
المؤسسات هي همم همم محاوله للتضليل بمعنى
انها محاوله لغسيل اموال همم ومنها تمر
العديد من العمليات الغير قانونيه والغير
الشرعيه
وعلى السلطات في مصر في لبنان وفي وزاره
الماليه وفي وزاره التجاره همم
تضع يدها على هذا الملف وترى اذا كان هناك
مخالفات للقانون اللبنانيه يجب ان ااه او
ان تصححها كما يحصل ان توقفها هذا هو
الاساس في الموضوع
اللبنانيه لم تفعل ذلك لان ضيف يقول بان
هذه المؤسسه تعمل منذ 2001 نحن لما بحثنا
في الموضوع وجدها تعمل حتى منذ 1982
تقريبا وهي موجوده في منطقه سوق الغرب في
الجبل مؤخرا كما ذكرنا ولكن قبل ذلك في
محافظات البقاع في بيروت بالجنوب همم
ضيفيه اطرح سؤال همم مشروع همم لماذا لم
تحقق الدوله اللبنانيه في همم نشات وتوسع
هذه المؤسسه
سيدتي العزيزه اولا ايه حاكم مصرف لبنان ب
19 ايار 2021 صرح وانقل ما قال جمعيه
القرض الحسن التابعه لحزب الله غير مرخصه
وبالتالي هذا هو الموقف الرسمي للجهه
الرسميه المصرفيه التي تتعلق بهذه المؤسسه
هذا من جهه من جهه الثانيه لا اعتقد
غير مرخصه وهي تعمل وتوسع هذا يدين الدوله
اللبنانيه قبل ان يدين المؤسسه بالطبع
بالطبع بالطبع يا دين الدوله اللبنانيه
ويدين كافه المسؤولين المؤتمنين على حقوق
وعلى مؤسسات الدوله اللبنانيه ونحن جيدا
بان العهد الاخير ولسوء الحظ عهد الرئيس
ميشال عون كان عهد الانهيارات المتتاليه
كان عهد همم سطوه حزب الله بطريقه مباشره
او غير مباشره على كافه مؤسسات اللبنانيه
لوضع لبنان في عزله خارجيه وداخليه ادت
الى مجموع الازمات التي نراها اليوم احنا
نعلم جيدا بان هنالك ما يسمى تحالف ما بين
المافيا والميليشيا وبالتالي الفساد
المستشري بالدوله اللبنانيه منذ سنين
وسنين تحالف مع
الدويله الغير شرعيه التي هي حزب الله
وادى هذا الامر الى الازمات التي وصلنا
اليها من جهه والى تنامي مؤسسات كالمؤسسه
المذكوره من جهه اخرى
انا اقوى كما قلت لك انا اعتقد انه ااا
حاكم وصفناه قال ان هذا لا تمد الى النظام
المصري في بصيله انا اقول انها وانا متاكد
من ذلك ان لديها ترخيص لكي تعمل بموضوع ال
هناك تقبل الله
ان تعمل في النظام المصري
لهدف
ليس كهدف البنوك والمصار في الاخره اليوم
سيدتي عندما تعمل كمصرف يجب على حاكم مصر
في لبنان لا ان يقول انها غير شرعيه يجب
عليها ان يتقدم بشكوى بالنيابه العامه
الماليه وانت همم وان لان له السلطه هو
الوحيد الذي له السلطه في هذا الموضوع هو
وزاره الماليه اذا كانت هي غير مطابقه
للنظام للنظام اللبناني وغير قانونيه يجب
عليه هو ان يقوم بذلك وليس اي طرف اخر ولا
لصلاحيه لاي طرف اخر بان يقوم بذلك هو لا
يكفي لاكبر سلطه ماليه ان يبقى ان يشتكي
من الموضوع اذا كان هذا الموضوع غير شرعي
على ان يقول هو بالاشرعات
لبنان في الفتره الماضيه قامت بحمله كبيره
على همم مؤسسه مكثف التي هي تعمل في مجال
السيرفر
والقرض الحسن ايضا موجوده في جبل لبنان
وكان بامكانها تحرك لو كان هنالك غطاء
سياسي ولكن لسوء الحظ لم يكن هذا الغطاء
مهمه جيدا بان هذه القضيه همم تدور بفعلها
التيار الوطني التحقيق
بان نعم
جهات الرسميه اللبنانيه
حاولنا ان نفهم وجهه نظر مختلفتين ولكن
سيكون النقاش بقيه اول شكرا جزيلا شكرا
القيادي في حزب القوات اللبنانيه ومن
بيروت كذلك مالك بن نادر الكاتب الصحفي
شكرا لكم